I want to ask I want to ask cat and chin
something did did somebody dip you guys
in adorable sauce this morning because
you guys are just adorable
what okay I'm questioning
was my question oh okay um I had a dream
about chance yes I had a dream but Jim I
get to the [ __ ] podcast and there are
men in suits and they go are you aware
that he is being investigated oh no or a
serial a series of serial killings oh
well so I I go okay
and then I go let me get Brennan out of
there because you were in danger
no well and I didn't so I I my dream was
I'm looking over chin I'm going hey I
need you tried like this yeah and you're
like what and you keep making the sudden
movements for whatever reason we knew
that sudden movements were gonna sparked
we're gonna get you killed your chin
yeah I was like like and it was a night
it was actually a nightmare of me going
like damn what do you go what's going on
like I kept hiding so you would turn
around so you couldn't see me dude if we
did finally get 3d that would for sure
again season 100% would be the theory is
there any way we can revive that oh yeah
really mean revive it redo it it can we
do one can we do fighter kids in ridi oh
yeah we get funding easily for that we
should gotta figure it out cuz because
you see it's possible don't go to
Jurassic graphics Instagram I meant to
recurse dude we we could we could I'm
talking about this on the podcast but
you and I I have the time you have the
time we could do it do you have the time
too tough we'd figure it out if it was
legit II you posted a clip when wilt
dared is in the middle of this wait dude
do you remember this alright let me see
it was just when the body was in the
trunk no he's gonna be part of the show
way too far
nice dude good that's a great show I
think we did a great job
yeah especially with the resources we
had I think we should do it again ah
well let's let's let's get Mitch Rosen
but let's go let's go bro let's get this
going let's figure this out I'm serious
man that was really Justin look you're
funding like this for that um do we have
all those on tape somewhere we have
access to those yeah I'm sure you can
find it you know what happens if you
type in friends get 3d on Google or
something sure read it or I need to go
cuz it's everywhere I need to get those
I'm proud of those I'm [ __ ] proud of
those men in fact he 3d calm Brandon's
repo on click on those replacement that
was a great one they can still buy for a
dollar 90 no mayo oh wow so people
uploaded yeah what the hell yeah I'm so
[ __ ] now you're really good to me so
many of those all right let's do a
podcast [ __ ] man
very very good that really makes me
think you know four years ago five years
ago we got to do again god we gotta do
it for real I mean I'm the one with will
where will comes in he's the bully
remember that mmm
III was a new employee in the in the
know thing is it wills a new employee in
the office and he's a bullies bullying
me and Brian we're trying to figure out
how to get rid of him and all these
things that you know there's all these
people everybody wants to shows and
stuff I watch that and I go that's what
I wanted cause it's so fun that's what I
want to do Wow I do I should call just
when we get off come up with a plan I am
all about it think about if I'm really
serious if you me and our boys got in a
room and wrote for just say six of them
six to eight of them then really some
star own yeah I think it's al I think
it's 100 percent with a box correct I
have a team that can shoot it that's
right
let's go games a scotch yeah let's go um
how much will they be able to watch that
gin I don't know if you guys find out
that you guys are cool to play it
through whatever however you did the
contract or anything I don't know I mean
what do you want to do I would try it
see what happens all right we will be
off for a while before if I can get
through you know put it out you mean
yeah yeah all right yeah I want people
to see it no worries and I think they're
the real the Haunted wood yeah they shot
it from like midnight to like 4:00 in
the morning cuz played that the offices
were haunted at Fox Sports that was our
weakest one but it's still good we just
one kiss chaos you know we have a game
plan
they fought us every step that's right
we're a friend do that yeah remember
from the ninja fight one that's great
that might be the best one daddy
so [ __ ] her today yes really amazing
[ __ ] alright let's go Mitch Ross is
awesome I wonder if this is his page it
is if it is then yeah you could just ask
him images I got a call Mitch is [ __ ]
amazing bitch's boss that was your first
acting gig and you were killing it yeah
do you remember my audition me that this
shit's a bad second I was laughing so
hard I was really good dude when you
click on the find the kid 3d there what
does have all the episodes I think I
might just say yeah yeah just the real
but I'll call him and ask him huh
I mean naked and afraid are these all
portable Madame Lau help that one's five
minutes let's watch that without
everyone
do you remember B yes phosphoric is so
good it watch these all day it was fun
[ __ ] man roll clip are we rolling we bet
it was watching it
god dammit we did that on no money and
with no time literally just like it like
will you Mitch and I would meet every
whatever whatever and we just went out
with ideas until something kind of like
I'm gonna go yeah please yeah it was a
hotel no it was a hotel this dope hotel
pally maybe or oh yeah right yeah Wow a
hotel that's right Mitch oh he's want to
meet there yeah that's good really good
and then we'd be stuck in traffic and we
get there an hour late it all worked it
all it all happened it was great oh man
I know hilarious yeah I feel like I feel
like there's no excuse not to do that
[ __ ] again and I feel like there's no
excuse not to do it every year
once a year so you have multiple seasons
I think man it's a good idea I really I
really think that because we have access
to the funniest people on the plane so
let's use them Tracy or what we just
hired a lot of actors we had Sasser help
out yeah anyone else thinks that the
time I mean yeah we will we oh yeah
oh we will yeah fun time to pull our
resources
let's get Rogen in there it'd be fun
yeah Monica chin and cat in there yes
why not oh yeah you guys are actors I'll
see y'all
obviously gotta write a one about Jim
being the serial killer I'd be great and
me get addicted to create them yep
shinza dealer I like that there's a lot
of a lot of possibilities man then he'll
why do you have a 2018 on your shoe what
is that dude it's just a celebration of
the year yeah really
huh cool love the year it's just a good
year yes how about when I pulled up
today my boys at cousins Maine lobster
truck was up I saw it they yeah they
yell out to me well I can't turn down a
[ __ ] grilled cheese did you get one
just now yeah well they were like hey
and so they yell at you because there's
no window there so that's weird in other
words I don't think that the only I'm
just asking a question
cuz if you look at that side of it
that's the side that I saw no if you
could turn it the others the other way
there's that see there I don't know what
where'd they yell from you hmm yeah I
put it it might be not just asking no I
don't know it might be your Lobby
Moscone to me cuz that's the side that
was facing everybody so yeah I know it's
weird right
they stick more as fewer the lobsters
that folds down don't think sound then
there you go Hey
so sorry so maybe they do have to try it
I don't know they didn't yell although I
want cousins Maine lobster right now
hopefully their woman you thought of
what makes it so good is that white
bread the Texas toast that [ __ ] Texas
toast that [ __ ] that's good stuff in the
mouth is well what's it cost about $13 a
$130 $14 for a roll
yeah 14:08 delicious
delicioso lobsters insects of the sea
and delicious logs of the sea brought to
the sea buddy bugs of the sea see my
first day driving in from the new crib
oh yeah too bad no 36 minutes that's how
be exact it's not better I'll bet you
got a yard all right take it easy
you take it easy you can take a couple
dogs you know this yeah got a couple of
these dogs make a couple hounds stroll
in the promisee I always have some
hounds drawing the premises a couple
hounds we got the connection double
hound bees I got some hounds that'll
bite somebody if they come come in here
you're Chris oh yeah yeah yeah you see
the house that court you're doing he's
still alive yeah did he pull recovering
that's an amazing [ __ ] recover cool
for sure calm down Jeff is screws and
everything his walk funny anything nope
nope Wow
they never really come back hundred
percent though do that he's young so he
did end the hug on the vet all the same
guy who did my dog's ACL and my dog was
a hundred percent he did her ACL which
dug my pit bull and she was she's never
had a problem now she died yeah she died
a cancer though uh-huh air was falling
off fish yeah when I first met I was on
the road when he should better
you had her that's right Lucy Lucy
that's right that's right I met her she
had one ear and it was juicy and by the
way when we when we went to the pound to
look at dogs and I wasn't even gonna get
a dog I just went to the pound because
we were bored one Sunday me and me and
my girl and of course a man who loves
dogs
I go we're not getting that dog we're
not getting that dog yeah and so she
started to cry but she was like crying
quietly like she was like I know and
then I look over and she's crying and I
go are you crying about the dog
because I just loved them and I go god
damn it so you got it I was a god and I
knew right then I had to get it was it
what is that crying can get you a $40
yes I'm like that crying and crying is
like better than a missile when a when a
woman when a woman cry like your
girlfriend yeah if they do it all the
time it's like no but if your girl cries
strategically and she's sitting there in
tears they're just gently streaming down
her face and kind of a turn-on it's kind
of a turn-on but it goes what's going on
here I got a story for you down here I
got a story on that that's so funny I
don't know what it is about that when a
girl cries it gets a man it gets you a
little for some reason it gets you a
little horny because you want to comfort
them and then you're like well it brings
you close to them it's like I was at the
bus stop train station how long ago was
this training I don't know the procare's
but let's say 15 years ago kay let's say
30 I'm at the train station in
Connecticut and this dimepiece but like
the kind of girl with lip liner and who
drives a Fiero with [ __ ] hanging from
them with you know I mean a lady that
works the nightlife worked the night
line lady of the street covered in
glitter smells like perfume and just
curves for all [ __ ] Hays Boulevard
huh yeah what juicy sweat you know the
remember the juicy sweatpants oh yeah
yeah and and and and just juicy in
general just all curves right and she's
just got that just frizzed out and the
whole hair everything is it is
everything it's the kind of girl yeah
the kind of girl that's a girl you're a
girl when you're with your girl she goes
what is this a lot how cheap she looks
so cheap and you're like I know how
cheap and you're gonna jack off exactly
today
yeah I'd download the obvious stuff hot
a [ __ ] I'll get the roll of duct I mean
I can see her nipples yeah like that
that situation so I'm looking at her and
her boyfriend who comes in who's built
he's just a big tank of a man just a big
burly son of a [ __ ] in sweatpants looks
like half a gangster and he's stand
there and she starts to cry cuz she's
leaving him she's leaving him he's
dropping her off and she's going back
home yes
he's like um and he's like he looks like
he's a mad he said I know come on hey
hey they're cuddling us up like that I
looked down he's got a [ __ ] really
pumping through his [ __ ] sweats it
was so inappropriate it's like yeah well
same to me it's close to you all the
life smells as he's Kissin ER and then
and then he's just he's trying to keep
his but his upper body forward so you
can't really you know suck him up in his
digs let them off no man she couldn't do
it there she couldn't do it there I take
it man and then he looked at me and he
goes hey I got a lot of tension I need
to relieve I was like wait can you I
gotta catch my train bro and he goes now
you don't go seriously bro bro yeah help
me out and he was big and I was like
we're in a train station I don't even
know are you yeah anyway that's not your
Connecticut role yeah my Connecticut
role yeah you Connecticut yeah that was
interesting dude speaking of sociopaths
that was specially that guy um I watch
that show or that movie solo last night
you know what I'm talking about the
documentary about the dude who climb El
Cap no real PAP with no ropes have you
seen it
I know I've not I've heard about it need
to see it that's Alex Humboldt or
something yes yeah right that kids so he
climbs this the hardest mountain in the
world with no ropes yeah I tell cap now
when people fall what happens is it's it
doesn't work out well no no one Falls go
man that was crazy
no you fought once and they don't tell
you how you thought once in a final time
but that's so nuts to me what he's doing
oh my dude will you watch it it made me
sweat it's just so crazy
he's so talented though but the way the
rock climbers describe it to go imagine
trying to pursue something in the
Olympics for gold and if you get silver
bronze you die I was like goddamn he's
right
look at him is there is there a [ __ ]
trailer on this I get so nervous with
this you can't play videos Oh
the less you play the better keep
yanking okay yeah that's I'll catch on
your own time that cell cap right there
it's L cap but in the walls like a
[ __ ] sheet of glass yeah but it's
interesting with his demeanor because he
grew up his father never showed
like you never you don't use the l word
he's super uncomfortable things they
they did a brain scan on him his his
area where like stimulus like to get
exciting emotion is just not there yeah
like it's they did something like that
with on sports science with really great
athletes and put them under stress and
they found that their their heart rates
didn't go up they just didn't overthink
things in make adjust his form his Derek
Jeter was that rhymer Derek Jeter Derek
Jeter would would play just play ball no
matter what like he just be chewing gum
and it didn't matter what the stakes
were he would just play balls the same
no matter why
yeah they're they're dead ball up 20
exactly exactly this guy federal highway
to this guy y'all great athletes keeping
him but this guy Michael Jordan Eddie
yeah so homeboy here though here's a
girlfriend and she's like she asked him
she goes when is it when is it you know
the future of us and kids like doesn't
that make you not want to do this
because if you die you know he's in
there isn't the love isn't gonna stop
you from doing this and he's like oh
absolutely now he said I don't feel that
is who he is
that is who he's been associate little
weird dude when dude but yeah I mean I
you should kind of be dispel he's he
hours on rocks alone well you can you
can you could so so they've done studies
asinine on what rock climbing what
surgery people surgeons rock climbers
painters and one other people who do
solos so so so it puts you in a state of
flow right so when you are up there you
have no room for anything but total
concentration I can think about and yeah
and and in a way you you you step
outside yourself that feeling is what
meditators talk about people of deep
prayer talk about and it's it's it's
impossible to compete with you're not
competing with that feeling because even
if he dies it's his life you had his
great that's what he says his girl is at
down ass [ __ ] - because she's not that
into the rock climb yeah but he has her
on these highest rocks and Wow in
there's times when he's beautifying over
the rope yeah she beautifully crazy and
she's holding the rope and [ __ ] up and
let's go
Falls and [ __ ] up his vertebrae and he
goes you know what it first happened I
broke up with her just because she
[ __ ] up on the rock and yes rock
climbing he thought about breaking up
with her I think he did break up with
her but then they got back together but
she's she's a down-ass girl oh and he
lives in a van yeah there's a van down
by the river yep the river because
there's nothing that competes with the
rock and there's nothing that competes
with that and so surgeons a lot of times
surgeons and arrow and conductors
conductors and and triple G so it puts
you yeah he does it puts you in a state
of true flow and they'd rather do that I
don't know if it's true flow because the
thing is the the stakes are so high
I don't have time to think about
anything that's life you don't have time
to think about his van his girl not just
got to be in the moment yeah that's
though as you that's the last name dude
I'm a fan that's truly seems a really
really nice guy but just a different
type of breed and he can do like one-arm
pull-ups all day and [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
I mean [ __ ] I don't know I tell me that
his fingers are super fat oh he was on
Rogen right yeah oh [ __ ] I want listen
that he that they show like the little
things like the little edges that they
hold on to dude I mean it'll nothing
well your boy your boy here did did some
rock climbing for a while and got to the
point where I was not good oh yeah oh
yeah I'm to the point where I was hold
on rock climb at door no storm no sir I
was on rocks real rocks counts got to
the point where I wasn't good but uh but
certainly got to a point where I could
get up a rock if it was a 5-10 a [ __ ]
what was the 510 like a high of a 511
maybe and God look at that dude I fell a
couple times where my buddy was holding
slack and resoling
solace sure was and I was on ropes now
there was a segue that I had to reach up
I had step reach up and stick two
fingers in a hole stuff and I go I can't
man I can't pull slack man you got to
get me out yeah again he goes I'm not
pulling slack in other words you're
gonna fall and it's you're gonna fall
five feet or whatever but when you're on
a rock you don't want to it's so
terrifying because what if you fall more
oh my god please step and stick that
[ __ ] mow I go I can't
my arms and you're you cuz you pump out
you can't move your fingers you just get
too tired again he goes down I go okay
and I and I try to go go he's sending
yourself life or death this is it and I
step and I go I guess why I don't even a
don't even reach remote did I scream
like that I fought maybe five feet I
scraped myself up a little bit
dude I can't believe this [ __ ] they do
how they're halfway up the mountain they
sleep on the side and the tents dangling
thousands of feet that's right it's not
that's right
I'm just not made for that I will say
this I'm also too big YouTube a climber
I would say this I did it for about a
whole summer and I did get a little
addicted to it it is incredible it is it
is look at that I like to move in my
sleep oh are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you kidding me they also [ __ ] off
the side you know that I'm sure no they
do I watched it look at that dude
come on and then then there's chill in
there when the winds pick up too and
they're like flapping around and they're
just in there with their coffee
I don't know bro this is so creepy
that's [ __ ] scary that's him oh no no
that's I am but there Oh bump in bumpy's
that's not ease that doesn't know they
obsessed up there - that doesn't make
sense to me of course you got a [ __ ] up
there that's that's an awesome place to
[ __ ] look at that dude are they just are
they living and the rest of us are a
bunch of [ __ ] I would say that's
living brother yeah like that's in
silicate I'm just cold it's just a type
of person yes you have nothing on they
probably ask questions when that that
that tent rips
oh they oh good question they die they
die look at them just chill it on the
side that's just not for me man now I
kind of want to do it but I'm Way too
big it's disappointing also you don't
wanna drop a shoe there because you're
in real trouble okay you and you in real
use in real trouble bro
using real trouble quatre chin you oh my
god quatre tini over Rockland no no
that's not for me no you did
I'm nervous not for me nervous watch it
you're nervous well I don't get why you
would do it look at the guys playing the
goddamn guitar also when you're oh that
might be staged for a photo but I like
it now if I have to puh do you pull off
the side dude I see I've watched him do
it how do I get super into rock climbing
yeah I believe it I like surfing and
rock climbing I could watch it all day I
had something about it I don't know I
like being out oh okay it's a little
different I like being out in nature I
got love to do that for like oh I don't
know half a day yeah half a day you have
it oh that's gross your fingers get
gnarly now Bach man
have you ever rock climb chin no never
you too big too big yeah you're a rock
climb no too small just not fan of
heights though you're scared of heights
yeah I think I'm meant to be in the
ground that's why I'm so short
that's legit all of us I think people
since we don't have wings are meant to
be on the ground although you see you on
Moscow is like it's in cost you five
hundred thousand get to Mars Wow
just be thinking shoot nuts so five our
thousand one-way ticket to Mars yeah and
then way around trip nope that's just
the one way oh you back but people are
saying you can sell your house and could
start living up there mmm that's your
plan it's gonna be a hard pass from next
next to the hard pass next to century
yes Wow it's still crazy
oh yeah pissed so hard dude
okay that's mother [ __ ] do it yeah so
no rock climb first you're too old I'm
too big just two big cats too small yeah
um how about I did our Boyd Jo koy
podcast yesterday yeah see nicest guys
in the world
he's the best man you know quite a beast
what a [ __ ] hilarious - is it calm he
made me laugh so hard we're talking
about you're talking about comedy and
how we just talking about how sometimes
we can be negative and like everyone
compares themselves to others and how
stupid it is and I said yeah like being
dead serial
yeah like if I sell out the Wilbur it
doesn't affect you sell out the Wilbur
like if I sell out once you sell out
seven and I thought I recall him selling
out like multiple times oh you sell out
seven it doesn't affect me I can come
back the next month and it's a good for
everyone we shouldn't compete and he
goes yeah seven you thirteen though
excuse me yes what's 13 in a row oh
shoot 13 or ellios yeah he said 7 I was
like oh yeah yeah 13 SiC tickets and
that happened when Netflix finally put
his special on the air because they
didn't for a long time do you know the
story with that
no so Netflix passed on it and he shot
it himself and then told Netflix Netflix
you can have it like I don't need to be
on Netflix yes he was big before that
though yeah it was a Netflix sounds like
you and you know getting Jonah cell of a
shitload before Joe's a great comic not
a good one a great one he's always been
an Isis diver yeah he's always been
[ __ ] hilarious dude he's always been
super supportive of me yeah he's a great
guy he's a brake gun always been a silly
goose always been a great guy I don't
see him enough he's one of those guys I
don't know he's so busy
come on anything oh yes she has a pot
yeah I'll be on there they leaked a bit
good I want a mom that would sells
serious dick yes he does
yes he does come see me in West Palm
Beach speaking of which mmm-hmm
yeah and then here the restaurant I
think his sister runs it it's in Vegas
oh really
and then his brother-in-law is his
co-host on the podcast damn that's
pretty cool man keeping it in the famine
in the family yeah that's one of our
fire to kid jackets I'm gonna send him
one yeah you gotta do it yeah yeah I
don't really see see him around the comi
stone no no I think when you sell that
many tickets to make that much money you
don't need to do the Comedy Store you're
like I'm he's on the road so much is I
come and stay home you think yeah I've
seen about there's some guys who don't
you don't really see like you don't see
doing the sets like Rogan does or
sword-like dillies there every night
yeah but Ilya is crazy cuz Thalia cursed
alia is crazy
big Chris D'Elia
has to do a set every night because he's
crazy ain't that right Chris ain't you a
little cuckoo bird who needs to know
that you know listen you know what the
comedy story you know it's stages for
Chris it's his [ __ ] pacifier
it's his blankie ain't that right Chris
okay man sorry dude um kind of went hard
on ya there's certain guys you don't see
really doing Seth around town but then
they just like it well I know she's like
an actress it's just me everybody has a
podcast man hmm it's just me all right
well she's beautiful she's hot yeah she
did a nude they yeah hottie paint thing
I was on she's your body [ __ ] she's um
Oh chin your fan huh Shaun HP I think it
was canceled though how to make it in
America I'll do I love that show up it
was about clothes yes yes she was in
there she showed her her boot that's
right yeah she was the girlfriend of the
Ming Greenberg yep
Brian Greenberg Erzberg town ain't Brian
Greenberg and Kid Cudi yeah one of the
reasons he got stopped because Kid Cudi
didn't want to do it anymore
putting a show about how to make you
American the kids created denim in New
York oh my brother a nice favorite show
there's a great fashioned and yeah
started with shirts and they started
moving up to denim it was cool man she's
been she's been quietly working for 20
years 25 years planet it's kind of
showing up many different things always
working the only thing I know her from
is failure to launch I think she did
that yeah
whoa that's heard in our Doreen she's
hot as [ __ ] Shh
they're and they're all real she's all
real Wow Wow she's she was well how old
is she's older now but she's still hot
but she'll curl your toes bro don't kid
yourself by the way good look at the one
on the you did in New York Magazine
right there where she's in oh she is the
husband I'd be yeah that'd be body paint
bro take a look at that I don't like
magazine covers do nothing for me that's
photo
Sheldon go to arrange oh yes she was on
how to make in America God that show was
good and was 40 I got old no she lose
her I mean what does she Bennett he's a
photographer what is mama
yeah Scott Campbell why do I know who's
got can't artist and tattoo artist
she'll have to Scott Campbell tattoo
artists Howard Stern sting Robert Downey
jr. he tattooed on them no he must be
really good pride tattooed her and was
like guess what yeah what some ink and a
dicksuck that's not I don't know if he
did that but make sure he goes stud I'm
familiar with his work
yeah very yes she's pretty there's a
small head fuzzy that is a head on him
huh he's got a head finger who does he
you wasted he's got a big like he looks
like a big British head I don't know if
he's British he means well
he shares a phenomenal tattoo artists
they're a good-looking couple
I've never yeah they did not think I'd
be talking about Lake Bell today on the
podcast nobody
you never know here you don't know what
we're gonna do they might watch our old
final kid 3d videos for 40 minutes and
then talk about Lake Bell and then ya
know and then we just move on we're kind
of willy-nilly on a rainy day rain makes
people lazy cozy all that stuff if it
rains like this I I would if I didn't
have to leave the house I may not really
I find rains are right for me and spurts
we rains a little depressing
that's I mean I'd that stay inside no I
don't like staying inside my son and
lacrosse seven years old and obviously
there's no today there's no the other
day was raining like crazy obviously
there's no lacrosse during the rain yeah
there is oh yeah oh yeah there is
yeah and you're going out there and play
you now with that [ __ ] ball see where
I'm from yeah you playing the rain to
play in the rain and you were a big
lacrosse player my son didn't really get
the game new to the game was like
running around running the opposite
direction like bride
tough game for a kid it is like Brian
doe with team sports and then somebody
said look you're taller than the other
kids
I want you to stop them from getting the
ball so you just hit their sticks so
with your she was like oh I can do that
that's easy
yeah next thing you know he's boxing
them out hitting them and it's [ __ ]
crazy
tough game for little kids it's like a
few like crafting my nephew plays
football you know you know you're okay
my nephew goes at the big kid yep he
goes uh now go out there and hit
somebody so Finn seven and doesn't
understand that so Finn goes out and
takes his stick and hits a kid right on
the head who is standing on the
sidelines did you flag pence wish to
give us right there and they had even
started practicing he just goes oh I go
what are you doing he goes he told me to
hit somebody I don't know hey bro think
outside the box here with him contact
Lee funny allergy um and he likes the
game of lacrosse great game in yeah
anomaly game yeah he likes it he likes
it it's an interesting game great game
well then one of the coaches listens to
fight on a kid got me some sticks I
don't know where the sticks are god damn
it oh we're like the chin thing you mean
you took the sticks it's like cool
thanks in no I did not I swear to God it
sat there with them I they're at my
they're at blocks their might the
accounts why would he give you sticks
well they reached out to me on Instagram
I was talking about lacrosse I did that
in that Instagram thing about six teams
okay you sound a real stick bro and they
make sticks and so I think it's called
strings or something like that or and
they uh and they sent me some sticks
catch with the lacrosse again yeah you
played a long time huh do you how long
do you how many years you play uh
freshman year then two years of college
so it's we all America six years six
years were you an all-american lacrosse
player I was Allstate and those freshman
the year freshman year yeah not bad not
bad
I love em dude love the game not a big
game but if you want a kid to go to like
a good IVs if he's that good you there
that Johns Hopkins academics in lacrosse
Kohan bowerbird do ya Virginia John
Hopkins real real academic institutions
Navy D you well that's like there
nephew's just such a ridiculous soccer
player in fact we're watching him play
like against Brent wouldn't stuff like
he's just better than everybody he's
just like he's you can see right away
that he's so-so at Campbell Hall the
record of the most goals scored of in
four years was 33
he scored 67 shattered right so he's
gonna go win yeah this he has choice it
off his choice of any d1 school but the
question was okay you want to go to do
you want school you can do anywhere you
want wait soccer anywhere you want North
Carolina yeah exactly however Williams
is not d1 but it's the best academic
institution so go play d3 ball and B go
to the best academic school you can so
that's the trans have to pay for it yeah
scholarship yeah but he decided your
sculpture dude you know cuz his dad
played pro soccer so those offers bro
cuz he's passed on a free ride to Duke
or North Carolina go play division but
but it's you know how do you want sports
is it's a full-time job practically
right so he's like [ __ ] it I'll just go
get a better education and interesting
yeah it is interesting it was like it
was a discussion to move it's a big
discussion yeah and our family to play
Division one I'm especially if North
Carolina Duke offered him yeah play
there I mean dude yeah and that working
it or gonna play it where's Williams at
it's up Northeast but it's a it's the
best school it's a good school but it
wasn't North Carolina ously Harvard yeah
but those kids getting their you know
their degrees from North Carolina to
shabby either or do yeah but you know I
think that kind of like that kind of
play yeah you know I mean do you want
sports is a full-time job right
full-time good yeah so it's different
yeah just a pants man with lacrosse
though Pro I they make $14 a day alright
yeah it's not good yeah it says is that
what does that mean Pro League he
watches it a pro league there's a pro
league yeah I know the studs think
there's us approach softball my buddy
Steve shucker played pro soft this is a
softball bro but fast pitch softball he
goes all over the world in place that's
a millionaire but that's not attitude
hold on oh it's soft bro hold on bro
don't ever compare straw
not a sport what Pro a man named your
favorite softball player I play softball
hey because you didn't make it in base a
home homeboy you know that they had that
woman woman in shoes at this you know
that woman that woman
fastpitch softball player who struck out
all those major league baseball players
you know I write you know about that
nothing could hit who host no those guys
could hit off of her you know that right
well y'all why because she's thrown it
completely different than you see yeah
might as well blindfold them who gives a
[ __ ] dude dude that ball comes across
that plate yes it's under this it's a
completely different release yeah well
just know that that's hard to hit men
still haven't played tennis I don't give
a f--- our team sport I love how your
wrist friend told you about pro softball
bro job bro we fly around you mean
you're rich friends put on games ruin
our world no don't be disrespectful the
pro softball he's is there a really good
athlete Oh double Jennie Finch now six
foot one that's a large girl do you see
the Instagram video I post first
launched and the t-shirt into the crowd
and it goes oh I don't know in the
[ __ ] bleachers oh I saw her throw
that that's her she's a dime piece too I
think that's her no no she's a big gal
you see her pitch no this is old ah no
this is yeah that's the whole thing of
wow let me see Jennie Finch f it let me
see her pitch right now Jenny we can't
play these videos we keep getting kicked
off because your weird obsessions with
why can't we so you can't even play
YouTube video it all depends but
typically we've been getting a lot of
issues cuz we do that like you listen to
music for 17 hours and so they kick us
off yeah it's [ __ ] up things but
let's uh from the 90s oh girl it through
the I think that's not the girl that I
post on my Instagram plays in the WNBA
she dribble these nuts in her mouth hey
man oh cool man bro look at how fast
that balls coming in dang crazy man that
doesn't look that fast huh
so you gotta face it dude I like Barry
Bonds why'd he get some of [ __ ] his
steroids right so what you stir it [ __ ]
off everybody he's still great that
Sarah didn't make him great yeah did
though uh uh definitely didn't make him
feel better
one eight ten Golden Gloves I did make
him feel good
sure it didn't yeah I don't how do you
know he took steroids I think he's uh my
god I think he's a I loved his earring I
think he's a coach now for the for Tampa
Bay or some [ __ ] like that really does a
god Mark McGwire was more impressive
though look at Barry Bonds in left there
young kid though yeah baseball was so
great when they were doing will hope
that home run race that was [ __ ] so
exciting but Mark McGwire and Sammy Sosa
were going after yeah I remember
everyone would be in the candlestick
park out there in the the [ __ ] ocean
trying to catch the home runs uh-huh it
was so cool man and now they're like oh
no steroids and then it gets all boring
boring I agree with you the homerun King
and then remember uh you definitely want
Marc Ecko bought the lot his last home
run ball 61 that broke the record and
yeah he had a vote on what to do with it
and he destroyed it huh why did you
strike I think he destroyed he put like
an aspect on it and then destroyed it or
something Oh because they put more gecko
Barry Bonds [ __ ] about that they're
so unforgiving it's cuz there was
screaming of chariots they're idiots if
they're idiots
cuz I never played sports in their lives
I have no idea what's going on finally
try brain yeah oh there it is to be
ended with an asterisk Barry Bonds ball
goes to haul ass tricked and all
Marquette goes faster than who purchased
ball in line for not Jeff 750 thousand
dollars
volunteers they the hall-of-fame
statements and them see this is old
Chango dish so I'm pretty sure yet
people vote whether to put in the whole
not and he didn't put in the hall but
mark echoes and babe ons baseball some
that's be a current one cuz that's when
it did 2007-2008 Boz says that go stupid
for getting rid of 700 maybe he did just
give it to them it's so annoying it's
like what are you doing dude you know
what are you
I think Babe Ruth was clean you think
Babe Ruth would have passed a [ __ ]
piss test well I didn't do steroids
Esther's not steroids I'm sure he had
something in that rankle on his blood
that would bet piss hot whether it was
drugs alcohol caffeine he's doing
something yeah um I my feeling is that
the amount of work that guys like Barry
Bonds they've got that could the work
ethic of Barry Bonds and Roger Clemens
was so legendary and you know I I
believe that stories allowed them to
play longer at a higher level of hundred
percent and you can say that you can say
that he hit the most homeruns because
his bat speed didn't slow down because
he retained his power he gained more
power 100% the steroids work we know
this and I understand I understand that
I understand that that's your point dude
but for me it doesn't mean you have to
vilify the guy no I mean I told you when
I was in Vegas and a-rod oh they're just
two beautiful women yeah huge a right
there yeah sure Iran all the guys that
might say what the [ __ ] that goin [ __ ]
kidding me
like why because for being awesome yeah
like just stare with me you didn't play
you didn't your warts you don't know
what everyone else you don't know and
keep this in mind we've got we talked
about this before but keep this in mind
you you you guys like I understand I you
could you could say that the steroids
are cheating yes technically you're
right but just for a second when you are
great when you're a great player
regardless and you if I put you in a
position where the game you love more
than anything if I said you get to play
this game listen this for seven more
years and I'll give you
another fifty million dollars just a
fifty-fifty right honey okay good let's
go up to a hundred million dollars
hey would anybody there say no or would
you do it because it's who you are it's
what the game you're not hurt but also
we all know that the whole [ __ ]
league was doing it so if you want to
continue you do it then continue and if
you want to compete that's the way
that's the reality of professional
sports dude it is the reality Giambi
brothers yes I still get Jason Giambi
yes huge hope there he is
Giambi still phenomenal athletes still
huge guys I mean you know I mean yes yes
steroids gonna steer it is I understand
for purists and people who you know it
is a it is a difficult subject man but
BALCO look at all the good look at all
the great players who do who oh by the
way when you're playing a hundred and
sixty games also you're at you you go
200 the Panther is row you you you break
down you want to stay recovered I don't
know I guess I'm saying I sympathize
with it and I I sympathize with it
is it cheating I guess technically it is
everybody's cheating in that game but I
don't know just some care events this
one she didn't do a psycho steroids I
would my brother actually got tested for
trying to do TRT if you qualify for it
but his testosterone is too high so I
think my testosterone might be too high
two years old into me nice I would do it
if it was low for sure I'm sure you
could go to a clinic where they won't
give up [ __ ] silver
I got hit up so much after we talked
about out by people you are offering
stuff like legit doctors just guys
trying to say stare testosterone yeah
they're trending they're trying to make
you a client judge yeah I don't know
what do you got dude okay so there is a
Russian island currently being overtaken
by a bunch of polar bears and it's
gotten so bad that they're trying to get
people from outside the islands to come
sedate the polar bears and take them
away because they've been attacking
people she Jesus Christ yeah
it's know how to
announcer it's a Russian Island holy
[ __ ] and friendly it's the Novaya Zemlya
zem la Zemlya chiba gelo archipelago
what is are conserved in such a mass
invasion of polar bears yeah they have
literally been chasing people that's a
hard pass go in there and polar bears
are the most vicious oh they will eat
you dude holy [ __ ] they like hanging out
and you know you can't do anything to
him cuz they're endangered species it's
illegal to kill them
I'm gonna grab shoot one of tomorrow yes
you're right in the stupid thing the
land sell holy [ __ ] man why did they
just all come out now on this tiny
island lease was they apparently their
ice is melting they're not finding their
food 11,000 view who's taping it is the
crazy part no that's a good point
well shout out the polar bears
everywhere what else so there was a
tiger found in an abandoned house in
Texas a guy tried to get into the
abandoned house just a smoke upon
entering the house he saw a tiger and so
he left reported it to the police and
they want to know for sure
are you just high and you think you saw
a tiger or was there an actual tiger
they went to investigate and there was a
tiger abandoned in the house that's
[ __ ] up look he's in a little tiny
cage trapped in there so folks healthy
though sucks though man limb stretches
legs of them go apparently there's a lot
of tigers illegally a lot yeah
illegally kept in Texas white tiger
kills zoo keeper in Japan click on that
Wow October last year white tigers dude
Akita does this show video no
they are they kill you pretty there are
there are things on there they grab you
by the neck and you just go quick I
think that's kind of terrifying a giant
cat like that just goes I'm gonna hate
you now Wow
white tigers Tigers are [ __ ]
terrifying
they're so big there's so much bigger
than a stupid lion well that Bank yeah I
mean what's at the hundo pan 800-pound
Siberian tiger yeah the last known
free-ranging white tigers known to have
been shot in 1958 oh that's nice for
which was right things in the wild were
made in India India has some [ __ ] man
yeah what's that
well most the most leopards em anywhere
are in Bombay in Mumbai in the actual
city they come into this you know is
they come into the city they have
infrared lights most lovely still dog
the world they still dogs in the about
$8 we're gonna have entire country wow
yeah
20 million people yeah they're just they
come in and steal hogs cats dogs
everything the [ __ ] with kids do or no
yep 200 people over the past 20 years
200 people have been attacked by
leopards attacked or killed
I don't know how many people have been
cut so grave a big animal so it's like
where I just moved I live super closest
secure and he goes do just be careful
with the coyotes is the only thing
really I said kids he goes not really
well the [ __ ] up dog dog that's
everything me and my buddy were talking
we're up in uh [ __ ] Kirkwood which is
a like off of Laurel Canyon we're
outside at 12:00 at night talking I'm
about to get in my car and we just see a
coyote come running up the hill with a
cabinet's mouth just sounds like see you
later my OD doing coyote coyote [ __ ] you
know right what else you guys got boom
so one of Bill Cosby's reps came out
recently and said that he's having a
great time in prison well I'm sure
everybody locked on I'm sure everyone's
cool with them
apparently he spent the first four
months of his sentencing in special
housing and he was just recently
integrated into the general public
although he does have his own cell with
no cell mate
apparently he's having a great time
though damn he hasn't drank any coffee
since he's been there now the funny part
about it mrs. Scott even trying to stop
from drinking after 55 years am i right
fine
that's not funny about Bill Cosby right
here isn't it took this stop drinking
coffee all right when I visited him it's
nothing sad about it he's not sad
he's not remorseful because he did
nothing wrong Jesus Christ
yeah the courts just got it all wrong
and apparently there are some other
people that live with in the vicinity of
his cells that help him walk around
because he has cataracts is the crazy
sighs of all time that I started going
30 years ago yeah and then they just
gloss over now hmm did he shoot a
special from there
yeah well sick from this prison so it's
so interesting I guess he's just hanging
out with the boys what else you're 81 me
hanging I was gonna say no you killed
Bill Cosby you're a dick yeah no one's
gonna shake you now everyone's probably
a fan but you know what unless there's
older dudes and they're the younger guys
don't know who he is like to me even I'm
a little yeah like he was these he's
[ __ ] the jello guy like and I know
he's a amazing comic it's a lie but how
many specialists is how many one hours
to spell Cosby oh he's a legend I know
but I'm too young for yeah like my dad
was super sad let's be sure and when
he's there you kind of you know you
still there oh yeah yeah mmm he's got so
many does he yes specials uh in the area
of 20 no and II dunno you don't know
your name is yummy total criminal Bill
Cosby above him he's incredible he's
eight he's the most prolific comedian
ever you know Chris Rock was talking
about it
I mean it's just like here yeah so it
was just everything
[Music]
pareo their specials so yes one two
three four five six seven more than that
well no I'm a liberal no no no yeah you
know you're probably right
69 70 71 83 87 he's got way more so so
from 87 to 2013 he's got a shitload I
have no idea why that might be what
maybe that's just who he kept oh yeah
he's got way more than cheating if you
google how many cons special you have
with a question mark I can do that only
has 60 oh no that's accusers yeah
there's only my ten might be on
Wikipedia I don't do this go to stand-up
career chin what no you don't need to go
specials just go stay on this and then
scroll help amount I'm there then they
go to ask Tommy strange they go to stand
up Jen there's here's a whole thing that
would stand up you scroll down let's see
it might be standard understandable
career right there let's see Cosby
Chicago he received now exposure led to
a recording contract alright released
the debut the first series of comedy
albums alright 140 great Scalia okay
Cosby performed his first TV stand first
in 30 years alright and 2 on 13 so now
that thing might have been right because
he did take all that time line huh
she said he performed his first one
after 30 years how something was right
here's about seven huh Ted's the the the
you know tens the most yes it yeah who
got ten [ __ ] home boy was doing every
year Mary's doing one year Oh Carla
yep yeah George Carlin he never stopped
touring I guess that's what it is he
never stopped doing stand-up like they
were talking about him Cosby about ten
years ago Chris Rock was talking about
it and he was like the Jerry Seinfeld
when Seinfeld did his special his uh
what was it his he did some kind of a
thing and they were like it's just
you've got to see him he's so amazing
Chris Rock was like he's just so
incredible look at George Carlin a giant
how about George Carlin though he would
only do material for a year then shoot
the special he was so prolific to all he
did it's all he wrote and it's it was
like what he did he was and really cool
tis to watch George Carlin a legend to
his first Saturday Night Live a bit on
Saturday he did stand up on did stand up
on Saturday Night Live and no one laughs
to the point where he goes if I told
these jokes before bring that up Jim I
told these jokes too much Carlos early
life it's mine really he did I mean you
don't even know he was it was so bad
that I was watching it I was I you were
watching it live yeah his monologue it
was Eva squab she's been on there a ton
of times it was his first stand here is
George Carlin on hosting the first
episode of Saturday Night Live no nope
this one no that's a shame talking about
it yeah he's on season one is it not on
YouTube should be yeah should be on
YouTube
it's it's just like mind-blowing there
you go football baseball no no is that
much the top ones those is it that
George Carlin monologue hosts the
Tonight Show tonight should hit well
that's only ten years ago that's in 1981
no this is this was why it'll be this
one it was the first time he ever did
Santana on the very first episode as now
that's it there did click on that click
on that that's a long time first host of
Saturday Night Live it's October use the
first half ever because how long is his
chin long five minutes I go four minutes
yeah well he bombs oh yeah he bombs well
that's crazy because even yep we have
some more turn event yeah so a lottery
winner in Jamaica collected his prize in
a scream costume to avoid showing his
identity they you know had very smart
using him get him yeah it's very smart
he waited about 43 I believe days before
claiming the price Jimmy got 158 million
dollars that's a lot of money 117
million US dollars I wouldn't be willing
to bet to one man of the night it's 1.17
US dollars like but it says ghost
basically claim 158 0.4 million dollars
yeah that's right Jamaican dollars
that's Jamaican but he probably owes
people money that's right yeah he's all
oh [ __ ] most super uh like most lotto
winners actually end up going broke most
of them from getting sued from family
members and hold Wow mmm-hmm I don't
know they also got broke because they
spend it now they don't know at the end
yeah
just same with any way you get massive
amounts of Matt away the [ __ ] the the
guy who said play when all the guys just
to play baseball
it's the softball like Jimmy Burke's
team they'd all go down there on Sunday
everybody played baseball drink beer and
hang out it's all ball and they play
touch football there was a guy who it
was a great guy and he'd come down there
and he would always have drinks and he'd
sell everybody beer
you know Ben Sentinel parking a bat and
backseat go $5.00 for a beer and he'd
bring down soda and beer for years for
years and he had no money and he was
kind of a homeless guy whatever but you
know that's how he made his living so
and everybody got to know Freddie I
think it was and they buy they buy him
bottle of soda he'd have his money go
back always well-dressed always a great
guy
and trying to make it work for himself
trying to make it [ __ ] work well one
day he won the lottery
Wow he won the lottery and he came into
and I'm not kidding he came into it was
about $100,000 that's it
something like that one hundred two
hundred thousand dollars right but that
he knew because down there there were a
lot of really successful guys who on a
Sunday loved him and they're like
[ __ ] they threw him a party or like
this amazing let us let us manage your
money for you
you know something because they out of
the goodness of their heart yeah yeah
yeah man thank you well
oh he disappeared and they're like where
the [ __ ] did he go
and Jimmy said that he saw him come back
about a month later and he was he didn't
have any soda in his hand and he was
wearing essentially a potato sack and he
had no shoes on and he was so dirty and
he was completely wasted he went blue he
went back he went off the wagon oh well
and he just and he didn't have that
money and he took him a month to go
through all that money somehow and he
just went back into the worst drug
stupor ever he's and that was what he
was and he just never came back those
lottery winners desert it doesn't work
out really not when you give somebody
like this it's the same thing with
college athletes like with a lot of
these college athletes or high school
athletes who get these million dollar
contracts or rappers that get hundred
million dollar contracts
yeah they don't know of course they
don't know how to answer the money the
first thing they should be it get is an
accountant and a money manager who knows
and take a class for six months on
finances so you take a smart cuz they're
gonna do that Brian make them know yeah
they're getting football in a football
you can do that right and football they
sit and take no absolutely not six
months I thought the end no I mean not
six months but and the NFL they they sit
you down and talk now are we talking
about the one seminar they have
oh don't do this one seminar don't know
your grown man didn't have time for that
no throw footballs catch footballs yeah
well they're not gonna be there was that
guy there was that baseball player who
was walking around with like nine
hundred thousand dollar check in his
pocket for eight months it's like you
could have been what are you doing yeah
what do you know but that's what I did
you know I would have done that I was a
[ __ ] idiot
no no but with my father and my my
brother-in-law sat me down because of
the money I was spending on agents and
all the stuff on business managers they
were like hey bro what is going on here
what are you doing and why are you
always out of money what's happening
you're making money what's what are you
doing I was like you're doing about 25
things wrong yeah and I I shouldn't I
should have known better and I was in my
goddamn 30s you know some people are
just you know I see more actors that way
I see I see so many actors that makes so
much money and I and I and I talked to
them and I see where their money's going
and I'm like man bro you have you have
less of an idea than anybody I know that
actors I know actors who are you know
who went broke up I've seen it and it's
a bad situation really stuff cuz there's
no even if you have a huge hit show or
movie yeah there's no guarantee there's
no longevity you go broke you gotta get
well you maybe or you hopefully get on
the next six era or something or you
don't get on the next super come and you
gotta sell your house yeah and the
problem is when you're an actor it's
exactly like being a fighter you don't
have any other skill sets like that's
when you've been doing that you were so
so now that's it like you know Janeane
Garofalo was talking about that she was
on stage and she was saying this is it
for me I don't have an option I don't
have a plan B I gotta either get that
job you know and a lot of people are in
that position so what does she get we
have this well I guess Jesse small it
has a Good Morning America thing coming
out tomorrow and he's angry at people
casting doubt on him like critics he's
like is there like us so most recently
the cops got a phone record from him but
it was redacted it had a bunch of edits
and sensors on it so it was definitely
edited dude what
top he's saying it's because he wants to
protect the people that have nothing to
do with it like his high-profile friends
on his whatever contacts list so they're
asking him to bring another one unedited
phone records I just smell a rat man I'm
sorry I wonder what happens I mean what
if it is she everything say there's
fraud I mean what if a story does turn
out fine no he's saying what if it's
true then it's true yeah I mean all this
stuff is just telling is all I'm saying
a lot a lot but everything's kind of
starting to pile on now where there's
nothing there has been anything to prove
that he is being truthful everything's
good pulling you to see it that's how I
feel so I'm like all right I don't judge
all right cool man you [ __ ] up I don't
hate him or anything yeah that's weird
here's a funnier one kind of cardi B at
the Grammys she received flowers from
someone on a car that said Tom Petty
so she think Tom Petty even though he
passed away less that's two years ago
she's such a character here it is thank
you Tom Petty for the flowers I left the
room but um and the flowers were very
big I will say thank you so much and
this it's a beautiful note but the
[ __ ] love me she sits look at Cheryl
so they just put Tom Petty on there I
don't think she thought I was the singer
Tom Petty you'd think it might be the
lyrics from a television host Tom Petty
is it is that varies from a Tom Petty
song
I think the note was the lyrics from a
song but I do think there's a lot of
times there's people that are passed
away that we just think are still alive
yeah that's true yeah it happens all the
time so if anything I think I do think
she probably thought it was him and
didn't realize he passed away that's
cool that Jaden Smith Jaden Smith right
there that is her thing it's just I
watch them know videos you don't see
that and whatever yes all right so this
is in 1993 in Louisiana Baton Rouge so
two cops dressed up as people with with
blackface and actually colored
themselves entirely how
so this is in 1993 right yeah and the
only people on their police force that
were black were only two people and the
whole city knew they were so they're
doing an undercover sting operation
selling drugs and they were actually
able to nab people by doing this these
two were yeah they're white guys dressed
as oh you know oh so they were doing for
the job yes at least officers also are
people upset about it so it barely
popped up like people found out they saw
it on a yearbook or something so they
you know obviously they're upset about
it so the mayor of the city and the
police chief they're all upset about it
shouldn't happen then shouldn't happen
now but the cops are saying that it was
actually something that they needed to
do back then like if he if they were
gonna do a sting on gay gay people or
yeah they're exactly gay they acted like
a I think in 2019 we are we are arches I
mean so we are so sensitive about all of
this stuff and blackface is the new
thing we just fickle about these things
but also we're gonna go back into old
yearbooks in 93 you did it then oh yeah
because we have a culture that says
here's a picture of you I don't know
anything about it but this is a picture
of you and that's who you are you're a
racist yeah you're a racist it doesn't
matter what you've done it that means
you're a racist because you had your own
black face doesn't matter the reason
either you know and I wouldn't I would
remind people back then a lot of people
that this was not we didn't have Twitter
and stuff and people weren't thinking
that a lot of times they just weren't
again soul man was a national hit it was
a movie with C Thomas how he was in
blackface he played a [ __ ] black guy
you have to remember these things you
have to remember historical context here
nobody was talking about that mm-hmm you
know what else we get you want a happy
owner sure man we got all right this is
kind of happier so this this old old
early older Asian woman was a mom she
went down to college campuses in
Maryland to see if she can find a woman
a girl that day [ __ ] son chin is this
your mom she luckily my mom was here
when this door
roaming UCLA guitars right now that is a
tiger mom that's how Asian parents are
though they just don't think otherwise
they're just looking out for your best
interest
as a kid I need they don't realize how
bad this is
would you would your mom do this cat
looking for a man does your mom like
your boyfriend she doesn't she likes him
she just is weird because I'm the first
child and I'm a girl and so that she was
kind of weird about that and then she
kind of caught on that my sister was the
one she needs to worry about like you
know we're okay I mean I think she's a
little bit of a PI a little crazy and
also a little bit over the board and
yeah trails nothing to do and then she's
probably like lucky single [ __ ] he's
getting older she's starting to panic
this is really common in Asian cultures
though they want you to focus on school
and career for so long without even
considering like dating or having
friends and then before long like you
just don't have anyone they're like wait
what yeah why are you're not with
somebody right now any smarter she had a
great degree and you're good at video
games you know whatever whatever it is
that the Koreans but ethnic Chinese or
whatever it is about certain cultures
like like ethnic Chinese and and Korean
for that matter they seem to be super
good at two things educating their kids
and getting them into Harvard and also
creating wealth you seems to lose the
other thing that does less happiness
well I don't know how happy I don't know
what the happy quota is on it but I
don't think it's good yeah no no I don't
think so
in China the kids I'm talking about in
the United States oh I don't know I
don't know because when you focus that
much on academics and jobs and that
thing oh here's the happiness and also
here's the other question if by doing
that how creative are they very very
good at something like business but are
they incredibly creative I don't know I
do know that a astronomical number of
ethnic Chinese kids plays at least one
instrument usually - well no that's
that's the other thing that I think is
interesting the work ethic and the
culture of excellence is huge and in
certain certain Asian called
well hope she found her son a a
girlfriend well they have you reported
her the girls did because she's
bothering all of them so probably not
the best tactic oh yeah so funny I feel
bad for the son me too
at least they don't release his name or
picture happy but this is mom's all over
off your mom's strolling campuses where
girl yeah hey mom go on tinder some fun
not sure there's an all-asian app there
is there's a really popular one uh East
meets East oh that's fantastic where
Asians meet other Asians or not being
why - go on there now yeah if you're
like looking for Asian girls really yeah
they're like white girls or like black
girls who sign up and look for a reason
I have red and only date Asian girls
like that's like almost are you friend
of me hey man you're an
equal-opportunity employer I am I do
love you yeah I think all races are
attractive frankly yeah be - there's not
one race that I wouldn't I mean hook up
with yeah yeah I've never yeah all of
them yeah the Eskimo is I'm sure there's
some time peace out you know if there's
some die peas that smell I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm eating whale blubber all right
yeah even if you have well breath I
don't care if you're hot enough I mean
you ever osceola the octopus breath uh
what everyone if you ever lost your
breath it's fine
you know I'm saying and if you if your
hands don't never get cold in the winter
if there's some dimepiece and Isis we'll
figure it out oh well the Arab women are
gorgeous as AT&T we'll figure it out era
where I had two Jordanian sisters take
pictures with me in San Diego and they
were delicious
I looked at both him when I went I'm
sorry and their and their brother it was
like I go that's that's a beautiful
family
took pictures I went I go you just
Accords me like worried from Jordan I go
Jesus Christ [ __ ] gorgeous like like
what the [ __ ] the whole family um that's
a hot Eskimo I don't believe these Jesus
that doesn't matter come on yeah now Jen
what's dope let me just take a look at
somebody who's actually from the Arctic
you her yeah
oh wow this is even crazier know what
it's not real is it that's not right
that's that's just a lifetime of living
on CEO hold on the Arctic win on your
face is not fun no it's not you're not
gonna have a good time your teeth get
that's photoshopped no that's a real
lady chin man yeah that's a real way in
fact if you smell real hard [ __ ] listen
I'm gonna say this something to be
honest I would never this guy this son
of a [ __ ]
you do look exactly like I'm a here's a
thing that you have better teeth if I
was missing a couple missing a couple
our Native Americans and and the Inuit
came from Asia yeah they came over from
Asia for sure man
well is that it mazing yeah that could
be it she's hottie she's not she's
Filipino she's definitely not Inuit but
ya know I don't know I don't I'm sure
there are attractive in you I don't
either
they're listening this very hot they're
good-looking people from every race
every race every color every John rrah
where are you gonna go I was gonna say
something but I'm not allowed to and why
there's one group there's one pocket of
people that I yes that are not
attractive let me guess small is a small
island no medium island yeah it's
England they're an indigenous population
to same island they were so isolated
nope
so isolated no cuz Africa's got
beautiful people and Helle everywhere we
talk about the Japanese know Japanese
very good-looking I love Japanese that
matter you can't say Hawaii no guess a
Fiji I'm sure if you were to look up
indigenous peoples of certain parts of
the world give us some ideas with you go
ahead and take a look I think I think
it's not Samoan it's not it's not
Tahitians not me none of that not Fiji
now it's just I don't know I don't know
dude I think there's no the the people
there
get in trouble for it yeah let's not do
it for you in trouble it's unfortunate
yeah well hey can you do it's all good
alright stop this right now
hey Bea you're gonna be in Palm Beach
bro you gotta fly out there I'm gonna be
a West Palm Beach come see me tomorrow
Thursday Friday Saturday I got five
shows baby yeah take it I can West Palm
Beach shake it on my Instagram tickets
of T pack yeah Tom see fat K calm or
tickets at Palm Beach improv calm um and
then I will be in Miami I'm back on tour
baby back on the road yeah Miami improv
March 15th through the 16th and then
washington DC washington DC March 28th
through the 30th DC improv tickets that
T that K dr. almost at the VOC theater
February 21st Feb 21st has to Thursday
VOC theater one show one night on
Vancouver Vancouver yes Vancouver at the
VOC theatre back T fat K dot-com get up
this the fine kid route